on attendait des réponses de la part du
premier ministre on n'a pas su en
attendaient des annonces des
éclaircissements une projection vers
l'avenir il n'y en a pas eu et au final
on a eu une émission de communication
spectacle une espèce de kovy d'automne
où le premier ministre edouard philippe
s'est mué en animateur un espèce de
mélange entre stéphane bern et michel
cymes qui accueillait les professeurs
qui nous expliquer des choses que nous
savions déjà d'une certaine façon
puisque les françaises et les français
sont aujourd'hui très informé sur ce
virus et sur sa propre un combat
propagation et c'était donc un propos
extrêmement infantilisant et par contre
sur toutes les questions réelles que
nous nous posions sur celle que nous
aurions souhaité poser au premier
ministre sur les réponses que nous
attendions il n'y a rien eu
le premier ministre a fait table rase du
passé comme s'il n'y avait pas de
responsabilité de sa part et de la part
des siens sur tout ce qui a précédé la
séquence que nous connaissons avec le
coronavirus et puis il s'est même
défausser sur le début sur le lancement
de du traitement de cette crise